la tension monte autour de l'église
saint bernard à paris danielle
mitterrand rend visite aux sans papiers
alors que jean louis debré affiche sa
fermeté
j -1 pour rugby en vrai de et elle sera
demain la première femme française dans
l'espace les obsèques de la petite boîte
doline sur l'île d'oléron et le deuil
des marins de la cotinière une
découverte française est peut-être une
solution pour lutter contre le
cholestérol l'opposition de l'inde au
traité de non prolifération nucléaire et
puis l'ouverture à atlanta des jeux
paralympiques
madame monsieur bonsoir c'est le
soulagement en belgique où deux
adolescentes de 14 et 12 ans disparu
depuis plusieurs semaines ont été
retrouvées saines et sauves re4
personnes liées à leur enlèvement ont
été arrêtées depuis un an les cas de
disparitions d'enfants d'adolescents se
multiplient en belgique
malgré les vastes campagnes d'affichage
pour tenter de les retrouver sur place
nos envoyés spéciaux valérie astruc et
franck vaillant de retour après deux
mois et demi de séquestration sabine 12
ans accueilli par tous ses voisins
c'était hier soir peu après minuit
épilogue heureux pour la famille et tout
le quartier
les avis de recherches jusque là
placardées aux murs ont brûlé même
accueil pour laetitia 14 ans elle avait
disparu il ya quinze jours c'est une
bonne chose tout le quartier ascq on
n'aurait pas plu beaucoup d'éléments
entrent katché et on n'y croyait plus
deux heures plus tôt les deux fillettes
sont libérés de cette maison proche de
charleroi séquestrée dans une cave
emmuré la police avait perquisitionné la
veille sans les trouver et ce sont
finalement les aveux des ravisseurs qui
ont permis de les localiser les
ravisseurs les voici
marc dutroux déjà condamné par le passé
pour viol à sa compagne et un autre
complice ils viennent députés le palais
de justice sous les insultes de la foule
les trois ravisseurs ne sont pas encore
inculpé d un premier diagnostic médical
affirme que les deux fillettes ont été
victimes d'abus sexuels
autour de la maison aujourd'hui la
stupeur règne aucun bruit n'avait attiré
l'attention des voisins
il savait seulement que marc dutroux le
propriétaire avait un passé chargé ou
dans la rue on nous a dit et redit sans
faire attention 25 pour la paix dit ça
mais tous les gens sont nous qui nous
habitent ici il ya un an et demi nous a
tous le monde ici mais mon beau frère
nous allons faire attention c'est a été
condamné pour des faits et tout ça les
trois ravisseurs sous les verrous tous
les pays respire mais il reste encore
dix enfants portés disparus en belgique
les enquêteurs espèrent donc en
retrouver d'autres car il n'exclut pas
que les trois ravisseurs appartiennent à
un réseau plus vaste de tes deux fils
la tension monte à l'église saint
bernard à paris où 300 africains en
situation irrégulière sont susceptibles
d'être expulsés dès demain danielle
mitterrand leur a rendu visite cet après
midi ainsi qu'aux dix grévistes de la
faim dans une interview au quotidien
ouest france le ministre de l'intérieur
jean louis debré estime que régulariser
ces sans-papiers constituerait une
lâcheté
anne gauthier et eric de lannion les
sans papiers de l'église saint-bernard
n'avais jamais vu ça une visite à
rebours à ce que médiatique
danielle mitterrand est venu saluer les
grévistes de la faim et a porté une fois
encore son soutien en famille
à me garer
on me suit devrait vous avez lâché le
gouvernement de céder ne compense pas la
lâcheté rivaliser dans l'église les
défenseurs habituels se succèdent
monseigneur gaillot a même interrompu
ses vacances est lui aussi sous l'oeil
des caméras
chrétien conditions pour ma part je
reste ici je vais coucher ici cette nuit
je reste avec mon sort est lié à eux si
on touche aux grévistes de la faim on
touche à gaillon tout le monde dit i
craint une intervention imminente le
ministre de l'intérieur est resté ferme
la date butoir fixée par le gouvernement
expire demain les familles en appelle au
président jacques cyr
ce qu'on demande c'est la régularisation
et on ne demande rien d'autre
maintenant c'est que nous avons
interpellé deux prend ses
responsabilités en tant que chef de
l'état pour que cette question là
prennent une fait une fin heureuse pour
tout le monde une nuit de solidarité est
organisée ce soir à partir de 20h pour
parer à une éventuelle intervention
policière
et ce soir lionel jospin demande au
gouvernement de reprendre contact avec
le collège des médiateurs pour régler ce
problème par la négociation au cas par
cas
en excluant tout recours à la force
claudie andrée 2 et sera bientôt aura
bientôt la tête dans les étoiles ce sera
la première française dans l'espace à
baïkonour les préparatifs se sont
poursuivies toute la journée pour le
lancement qui doit avoir lieu demain
patrice pollet et claude sicard protégé
par une baie vitrée pour éviter toute
contamination microbienne
avant son départ voici que le dit andré
d lorsqu'elle arrive ce matin
pour sa dernière conférence de presse
avant de quitter la terre pour claudie
la première française à partir dans
l'espace
l'occasion d'évoquer sa mission est
aussi de parler
je crois que pour les femmes cet accès à
la recherche à la médecine c'est déjà
quelque chose d'acquis depuis l'enfant
si je peux leur montrer qu'on est allé
encore plus loin
bon donc fait dessus dans la
confirmation du rôle de la femme est
bien sûr c'est un message que je délivre
avec l'atmosphère se détend son médecin
et le cnes nous organise une rencontre
où nous maintient à distance toujours
pour cause de micros et de 24 donc de
l'attention de la pression de l'émotion
il y en a mais nous sommes des êtres
humains c'est normal de leur sang tiers
et je suis heureuse d'avoir ces
sentiments-là et de pas rester de glace
devant un événement aussi important à
une aventure aussi formidable que celle
que je vais vivre
bassila la dernière ligne droite ça fait
longtemps qu'elle est dans ce volet
maintenant pour elle cet épanouissement
elle est prête elle se sent prête donc
est la proie du coup de stress
particulier et elle est dans quel con et
puis ce matin lors d'une grande réunion
soupeser les responsables russes ont
annoncé lundi qu'elles étaient
définitivement retenus dans l'équipage
qui part d'hommes soulagée elle nous a
créés sur cette dernière photo de
famille rendez vous demain
cette fois ci en tenue de cosmonaute
avant l'embarquement dans la fusée
soyouz
alors avec nous en direct de baïkonour
patrice pollet bien sûr et michel
courtois le directeur du centre spatial
de toulouse michel courtois vous
connaissez bien que le dit andré aidé
puisque vous l'avez en quelque sorte
chaperonner on a d'abord envie de vous
demander pourquoi at il fallu attendre
si longtemps pour avoir et pour voir une
femme dans l'espace eh bien les premiers
astronautes que nous avons entraîné que
nous avons désiré faire voler était plus
que des pilotes d'essai la vocation
était surtout à l'occasion du projet
hermes d'avoir des individus capables de
piloter l'avion de retour
donc c'est ce qui explique les premiers
qui ont volé était depuis le décès jean
chrétien patrick baudry et depuis
quelques mois
d'abord le projet hermes a notablement
évolué puisqu'il a été arrêté et puis
maintenant vous on appelle des gens qui
sont plutôt scientifique et qui savent
un peu mieux ce que sont les opérations
et les expériences qui sont à bord
ils font plus qu ils soient physiquement
à pouvoir sur le vol
alors michel est ce que claudie en raid
et un suivi le même entraînement a
autant souffert qu'un homme mais n'y a
pas de séparation il n'y a pas de pitié
ni pour les sommes dues pour les femmes
donc les séances d'entraînement physique
musculation tabouret tests médicaux tout
ce qui permet de détecter ce qui
pourrait être une déficience physique ou
pré difficulté en orbite tout ça un bout
femmes les deux le subissent y a pas de
difficultés particulières pour une femme
à se trouver dans l'espace par rapport à
notre la même chose en fait non c'est le
même environnement ce sont les mêmes
expériences sont les mêmes opérations
qui sont conduites l'entraînement est
identique
la formation est identique également
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que les
équipages dit à l'équipage doublure
c'était avec léopold eyharts ce qu est
un homme qui est un pilote vie et donc
ils ont subi strictement le même genre
de formation alors une petite chose
s'ils voulaient bien puisque vous la
connaissez bien ce que vous pouvez nous
dire un petit peu les défauts et les
qualités bien sûr de 2 kg audrey devait
à cette faillite et c'est comme que ce
disque en voilà que je la connais
personnellement je trouve c'est
quelqu'un qui a un moral et a tenu
simplement fantastique
une personne qui est extrêmement
volontaire des défauts je ne connais pas
c'est pas que je veux pour dire je
reconnais pas vraiment les d'humeur
égale et ça c'est quelque chose plus son
sang froid
c'est ce qu'il faut pour quelqu'un qui
perdrait espace parce qu'il faut pouvoir
faire face à des situations imprévues et
pouvoir réagir correctement le décollage
de leur patrie ce sera demain au jeu
suivant sur france 2
je vais écouter demain ça sera sur
france 2 d'abord à 13h on verra claudie
andré deshaies l'équipage donc s'équiper
métro les scaphandres et puis surtout je
vous donne rendez vous donc demain à
partir de 15h15 le lancement ça sera à
15h17
à ce moment-là claudine andré dsk ici
dans le frioul tout à fait au bout là
dans la capsule
et ça se passera en direct sur france 2
pour la première fois du cosmodrome de
baïkonour pour ceux que ça intéresse ou
bien c'est à 400 km au nord-est de la
mer d'arabie en israël on vous suivra
bien sûr merci en tout cas à vous deux
claudine andré 2 et va passer donc 16
jours à bord de la station mir elle y
mènera des expériences biologiques et
médicales pour voir comment un homme
peut vivre en bonne santé et travailler
efficacement lors de longs séjours dans
l'espace
le programme duval le programme du ve
et particulièrement chargé jean claude
allanic quand claude et andrée de s
installera demain dans la capsule soyouz
cette fois ci ce ne sera plus un
exercice de simulation mais bien le
départ d'une grande aventure spatiale
une aventure au cal claudie se prépare
depuis déjà onze ans depuis sa sélection
dans le corps des spationautes français
du cnes c'était en 1985 elle était à
leur médecin rhumatologue être mais ça
ne peut pas être la seule compétence
qu'on est quand on devient un cosmonaute
au fur et à mesure de cette année je
suis aussi devenu un petit peu ingénieur
ingénieurs dans différents domaines
et c'est ainsi qu'elle s'est spécialisée
en biologie en biomécanique en
aéronautique et en informatique un
cursus équivalent à bacchus 19
de quoi être bien armé pour effectuer
les nombreuses missions scientifiques
qui l'attendent dans la station mir
mais ce n'était pas encore suffisant
pour devenir la première française à
conquérir l'espace pendant près de trois
ans à la cité des étoiles
claudine andré deshaies a donc suivi
l'entraînement de tous les cosmonautes
russes un entraînement très physique qui
n'a pas de point rebuter cette ancienne
championne universitaire toujours
souriante même quand il s'agit
d'affronter l'épreuve redoutable de la
centrifugeuse et du tabouret tournant
oui bien sûr c'est pas très agréable
c'est plutôt déclencheur de nausées d'un
groupe fort heureusement dans ses pas
trop souvent
on février dernier l'audi andreu des
était déjà dahico moore pour assister au
lancement d'un équipage russe vers la
station mir
il était alors qu'un au revoir pour ses
deux coachs de l'autre qu'elle partira
rejoindre demain aux états unis la
course à la maison blanche est
officiellement commencé pour le
républicain bob dole pour son discours
d'investiture il s'est voulu résolument
optimiste promettant de restaurer la
croissance économique les valeurs
morales de l'amérique des années 50 et
la survenue de la supériorité militaire
des états unis un discours aux accents
regagne 1 à san diego
bruno dref il triomphe il le veut cela
fait 16 ans que bob doll attendait cet
instant après trois tentatives
infructueuses il remporte enfin
l'investiture républicaine
embrassades confetti's et ballon rien
n'a manqué à ce qui devait être la
grande fête du parti républicain
le point d'orgue fut comme prévu le
discours de bob doll ses adversaires le
disent trop vieux 73 ans il a critiqué
la génération de clinton 50 ans il a
confirmé qu'une fois au pouvoir ils
baisseraient les impôts de 15% et a
accusé mme clinton de mollesse nous
poursuivrons les terroristes au bout du
monde
le pays a besoin d'un vrai chef
militaire idée force de son discours
je suis l'homme qu'il faut car j'ai
souffert et survécu à une époque j'ai eu
peur de l'avenir
mais j'ai appris que les obstacles
peuvent être contournés j'ai une
confiance illimitée dans la sagesse de
notre peuple et le futur de notre pays
après trois journées d'une convention
quelque peu fade
daul a donc mobilisé des troupes toutes
prêtes à s'enthousiasmer
il a comme prévu gagné une bataille mais
c'est une guerre qui l'attend pour les
82 jours qui restent avant l'élection
présidentielle
alors philippe gassot bonsoir vous êtes
à san diego en direct ce qu'on peut dire
que bob dole se renforçait cette
convention républicaine mais écoutez
c'est un petit peu trop tôt pour le dire
mais je peux vous livrer les derniers
sondages ont été réalisés il ya 24
heures
bob dole avait une vingtaine de points
de retard sur le président bill clinton
maintenant il n'en compte plus que 11
mais il faut dire que depuis une semaine
bob doll occupe les médias c'est la
presse écrite ce sont les radios se sont
toutes les télévisions
donc il est bien évident comme on dit
ici que hot doll a été boostée risée en
avant mais est-ce que ça va durer c'est
une autre histoire
laurie sur le fond sur sa politique
maintenant on sait qu'ils qu'il a une
une aile très très conservatrice dans
son parti est ce qu'on connaît un peu
mieux la politique il va appliquer bien
la politique ce n'est pas exactement le
sujet qui a été abordé
on sait très bien qu'ils aient à la
christine coalition qui veille de très
près à la rigueur du discours de bob
doll il s'agit bien entendu de
l'avortement
et lorsque l'on parle de tolérance aux
personnes qui étaient largement
représentés au congrès le mot tolérance
est une injure c'est une trahison et on
sait très bien aussi que l'immigration
ne conçois aucune tolérance
hier bob dole disait immigration zéro
pour les illégaux
on ne sait pas comment il va faire et
lorsqu'on regarde la presse de ce matin
on peut lire on peut lire à la une de
usa today we trust in the people je
crois dans le peuple vous voyez qu au
niveau de la déclaration politique c'est
un tout petit peu faible merci beaucoup
philippe et puis sachez que dans
l'enquêté sur la catastrophe du boeing
de la têt w à le quatrième réacteurs de
l'appareil ont été repêchés aujourd'hui
mais les enquêteurs du fbi elle redoute
que les preuves d'un éventuel attentat
est à jamais disparu dans l'océan large
de l'ong island
des chercheurs lillois sont peut-être à
l'origine d'une petite révolution pour
lutter contre le cholestérol
ils ont mis en évidence une substance
naturelle fabriqué par notre organisme
et qui serait capable de purifier les
artères des dépôts de cholestérol
les médicaments ne sont pas loin et
cette découverte fait rarissime fait
l'objet d'une publication dans la
prestigieuse revue scientifique science
jean daniel flaysakier et vincent
maillard
pour faire les pieds au mur et même
quand on est une souris il faut avoir le
coeur solide solides elles le sont les
pensionnaires de cette bulle stérile
on les a nourris de gâteau deux coupes
d'aliments gras et pour autant leurs
artères ne se sent pas encrassé de
cholestérol il faut dire que ce sont des
souris un petit peu spécial quand elle
n'était qu'à l'état d'embryon les
chercheurs les ont dotés d'un gène
supplémentaires un gène humain qui
fabrique une protéine que l'on appelle à
pau à 4 et la peau à 4,7 apparemment
très efficace contre l'excès de
cholestérol à ce fameux cholestérol il
est indispensable à notre vie mais il a
parfois de mauvaises idées comme celle
par exemple de se faire transporter dans
le sang par une protéine qu'on appelle
ldl et la ld elle va déposer le
cholestérol à l'intérieur de nos artères
au risque de les exprimer
heureusement il ya aussi dans notre sens
d'autres protéines qu'on appelle hdl et
qui peuvent remporter ce cholestérol
vers le foie pour le détruire la peau à
quatre c'est aussi faire l'éboueur et
emporter du cholestérol vers la
destruction
chez les souris on s'est aperçu qu'elle
avait une particularité encore plus
intéressante elle semble pouvoir
s'attaquer directement à la plaque de
cholestérol dans les vaisseaux est en
quelque sorte aider à récurer les
artères cela c'est très nouveau et c'est
particulièrement intéressant si ceux ci
étaient confirmés et c2 le but de
travaux actuellement on peut penser que
à court terme à moyen terme on
n'arrivera à avoir une influence majeure
sur les dépôts de cholestérol dans les
artères coronaires par exemple on
cherche maintenant à stimuler la
production de la peau à 4 la piste des
médicaments se précise c'est l'éternel
combat de la matière grise contre la
matière grasse un rebondissement dans
l'enquêté sur le financement occulte de
l'ancien à cds lancer un parti politique
selon l'hebdomadaire le point
l'état major de l'époque messieurs
méhaignerie barreaux et arthuis ça
aurait été mis en cause par les
trésoriers du parti la scène se serait
déroulée dans le bureau du juge
d'instruction olivier caroff mars 1995
pierre méhaignerie autorise la justice à
enquêter sur le financement occulte de
son propre parti
le canard enchaîné avait révélé à l'est
poc l'existence de comptes en suisse
abritant des fonds du cds
aujourd'hui selon le point l'ancien
garde des sceaux au risque de se
retrouver dans le collimateur de la
justice
avec les ministres centristes jacques
barrot et jean arthuis car dans le
bureau du juge dan auto chargé de
l'enquète trois responsables des
finances du cds ont commencé à parler
l'un d'eux françois froment-meurice
avait déjà reconnu être le trésorier au
culte du cds la direction du parti selon
lui était au courant entre l'été 88 et
le printemps 89
lorsque pierre méhaignerie président est
le cds un comité financier dirigé par
jean arthuis aurait même pris l'habitude
de se réunir à l'assemblée nationale
autre découverte du juge hanotaux
révélée par le point un rapport d'audit
sur la gestion du cds surendettement
multiplication des comptes en banque et
destruction de pièces comptables les
conclusions sont accablantes
mais la plupart des faits incriminés
remontent à avant 1990 et pourrait donc
être amnistiés et commentaires de jean
arthuis le ministre de l'économie et des
finances il qualifie d' inexact et les
informations du point
jacques barrot lui affirment qu'ils
n'étaient pas informés des mécanismes du
financement du parti quant à pierre
méhaignerie
il apparaît ch les habitants de l'île
d'yeu vont se rendre aux urnes dimanche
leur conseil municipal a démissionné en
juin pour protester contre l'application
de la loi sur le littoral qui paralyse
ce qui paralyse
selon le maire sortant tous les projets
de construction sur l'île sur cette
campagne estivale le reportage de marie
pierre farkas et maryse richard des
criques de granit à l'abri des vents une
lande interdite aux promoteurs c'est
l'île d'yeu côté ouest sur son versant
sauvages tels que la percevaient les
thoniers au début du siècle
après de longues semaines en mer des
tuiles rondes à perte de vue des
bataillons de touristes qui débarquent à
la gare maritime en pleine saison celle
il y eu des temps modernes celle des
bâtisseurs ou marchands de loisirs
aujourd'hui plus nombreux que les
pêcheurs en jeu à le préfet a refusé d'y
permis de construire depuis c'est la
tempête au village
il va bien falloir un jour arrêter de
construire sur l'union si l'on est pas
que les constructions ne sont pas
obligatoires moi un jour le brassard
était alors évidemment il y en a
peut-être arrêter vincent sont engueulés
curé assuré comme un vrai quand même
voici environ 380 comme un citoyen dans
le bâtiment sera assumée alors il faut
bien j'arrive à faire la sphère est au
point mort depuis deux mois le maire a
démissionné son ancienne équipe a
reformé de liste pas vraiment de
concurrence mais deux méthodes pour
sortir du conflit immobilier
si vous êtes maire dimanche vous
commencez par faire quoi ah on commence
à organiser organisé justement le
dialogue comme préconise depuis très
longtemps dialogue avec les instances
supérieures bien sûr et dialogue avec la
population ça nous paraît essentiel
un candidat presque dialogue l'autre
service mairie qu'il pourra me dossier
avec le préfet il faut adapter la loi
littoral à l'île d'yeu comme sur
d'autres il d'ailleurs mais sur sur les
lieux il faut l'adapter il faut la
moduler pour lille continuait à faire
des petites maisons comme vous voyez des
petites maisons blanches aux toits
rouges comme ça se fait l'île d'yeu
depuis déjà des années on voit à peu
près ce qu'ils vont nous proposer mais
on sait quand on sait ce qui nous attend
alors vous attend quoi
par contre je viens certains y leon
t'acheter une fortune des terrains qui
aujourd'hui ne valent plus rien parce
qu'il ne souffre plus constructive
d'autres ont tenté de résister aux lois
dictées par le continent mais les
familles les lecteurs de l'île d'yeu
savent que protégé littoral c'est
garantir à lille son allure éternelle le
journal officiel a publié le décret
d'application de la loi robien sur
l'aménagement du temps de travail un
texte qui prévoit des allégements de
charges pour les entreprises qui
diminueront de façon significative le
temps travaille les explications de
mélanie magot et jean-paul chapelle ici
on travaille deux heures de moins par
semaine
cette réduction des horaires a permis à
l'entreprise fleury michon de créer des
emplois un exemple qui marche
un exemple que la loi robien tend à
généraliser l'employeur qui réduit de 10
pour cent le temps de travail et
augmente ses effectifs de 10% vous à
bénéficier d'une exonération des charges
patronales 40 % la première année 30%
les six années suivantes des cotisations
sociales prises en charge par le budget
de l'état
un cadeau du gouvernement bien
accueillie par les chefs d'entreprise
alors là je crois que c'est une bonne
mesure les entreprises les salariés les
syndicats doivent jouer le jeu pour
faire en sorte que cette mesure soit un
succès les syndicats pourront négocier
une compensation salariale pour ceux qui
travailleront moins
la loi concerne aussi les entreprises en
difficulté qui renonce à licencier une
mesure qui inquiète les syndicats
elle ne va pas créer des emplois puisque
pour l'essentiel elle va être utilisée
dans sa forme dites défensives
c'est-à-dire d'accompagnement des plans
sociaux dans lesquels honnie au prétexte
d'éviter des licenciements
on va imposer une réduction du temps de
travail quelquefois avec réduction du
salaire la loi le prévoit
innovation supplémentaire cette aide
sera cumulable avec d'autres mécanismes
de soutien à l'emploi
un dispositif qui sera utile aux grandes
entreprises publiques en difficulté le
crédit lyonnais et j'ai hâte industrie
prépare justement leur plan de
restructuration
à l'étranger la situation reste très
tendue à chypre pour les obsèques d'un
chypriote grec tué mercredi par des
forces turques
il n'y a pas eu de nouvelles victimes
les casques bleus et la police chypriote
grecs avaient été placées en état d'
alerte maximale
dans son oraison funèbre devant des
milliers de personnes l'archevêque de
chypre a exhorté les jeunes grecs à
éviter toute nouvelle action pour donner
aux dirigeants le temps de faire leur
travail
un coup de théâtre à genève après trois
ans de négociations l'inde s'oppose au
traité d'interdiction des essais
nucléaires
un texte pourtant défendue par la france
et les états unis
cette position de l'inde risque de faire
tâche d'huile le pakistan voisin a déjà
fait savoir lui aussi qu'il ne
ratifierait pas ce texte
les explications de thierry thuillier le
15 août est un jour de fête en inde
c'était hier le 49e anniversaire de son
indépendance
une occasion en or saisi par le premier
ministre indien d'afficher sa fermeté en
invoquant les intérêts vitaux de son
pays ou des lilas annoncé il n'y aura
pas d'adhésion indienne un futur traité
d'interdiction des essais nucléaires si
les grandes puissances ne révise pas
leur position
il n'y a pas d'engagement de la part des
puissances nucléaires qui sont déjà
dotés d'armes nucléaires et même d'un
nombre très important de ces armes de
procéder à un croyant de désarmement
conséquent concret et sur un calendrier
précis
il n'y a pas d'obligation dans ce traité
envers ces grandes puissances nucléaires
voici donc aux négociations de genève
les états unis la russie la chine le
royaume uni et la france épinglée
le club des cinq accusés de vouloir
garder le monopole de l'arme nucléaire
en empêchant tous les autres pays
d'acquérir la bombe
or l'inde qui a déjà procédé à un essai
nucléaire en 74 serait avec israël le
pakistan sur le point de produire sa
propre bombe qui plus est new delhi a
deux voisins la chine et le pakistan qui
coopèrent en matière nucléaire et avec
lesquels les relations sont tout sauf
sereine et confiante
alors plaint date choisie le blocage au
risque de l'isolément
conséquence le grain de sable indien en
veille toute la machine pour être
appliqué le traité doit être adoptée par
tous les partis
à la conférence de genève à son retour
de tchétchénie alexandre lié bed exige
le limogeage du ministre russe de
l'intérieur ce sera lui ou moi dit il
pour débloquer la crise tchétchène et
puis on vient de l'apprendre le
commandant des forces russes et le chef
de l'état-major indépendantistes
tchétchènes devrait proclamer
officiellement demain un cessez le feu
sur l'ensemble de la tchétchénie
cinq gendarmes français sont arrivés ce
matin en angleterre ils sont chargés
d'enquêter sur le viol et le meurtre de
caroline dickinson cette jeune anglaise
assassiné dans une auberge de jeunesse à
pleine fougères jacques cardoze et
robert olive après une nuit passée à
bord d'un ferry les cinq enquêteurs
français sont arrivés ce matin dans la
petite localité de l'endss ashton dans
leurs bagages les dossiers concernant le
viol et le meurtre de caroline dickinson
des éléments qu'ils ont fournis à leurs
homologues britanniques
dès leur arrivée mais les gendarmes
français ont promis de ne faire aucune
déclaration
je suis surpris parce que en langue
était si les policiers nous donne des
informations sur les projets de
l'enquète il nous donne les contrastes
pressé est au juge je peux téléphoner
pour demander des informations
les informations c'est le proviseur du
collège et le prêtre du comté qui ondule
et fournir cet après midi les enfants se
prêteront sans aucun problème aux
interrogatoires ont ils déclaré
et s'il doit y avoir des relevés
d'empreintes génétiques cela ne choquera
sûrement pas les parents sachant que les
interrogatoires sont menés par la police
anglaise selon notre système légal
c'est un vrai confort pour les enfants
et les parents les enfants se sentent
prêts à donner toutes les informations
qu'ils pourront et je suis sûr qu'ils le
feront aussi pour les autorités
françaises française et anglais doivent
d'abord se mettre d'accord sur la
procédure qui débutera véritablement
lundi pour les policiers l'après-midi a
donc été consacrée à l'examen du dossier
avant l'arrivée des enfants compagnons
de voyage de caroline
derrière ces murs de l'hôtel de police
de lens 16 tonnes les gendarmes français
ont donc entamé une nouvelle enquête
depuis ce matin celle ci devrait durer
15 jours peut être trois semaines le
temps nécessaire pour obtenir le
témoignage des quarante enfants du
collège mais les enquêteurs français ont
prévenu la presse on ne saura rien de
ces entretiens
à moins à moins qu'un des adolescents
fasse des révélations
un mois après le meurtre de caroline
dickinson la cotinière en deuil cet
après midi pour les obsèques de la
petite gwendoline les habitants du port
de l'île d'oléron ont rendu hommage à la
fille du patron de l'essor mortes dans
le naufrage du bateau de son père
dimanche
les marins avaient demandé au caméraman
et aux photographes de se tenir à
l'écart pendant la cérémonie patrice
volée et delphine wii one doline avait
sept ans et il y avait foule pour son
dernier voyage
une foule au silence impressionnant dans
l'église et sur le port de la cotinière
marin et touristes unis dans le même
recueillement
elle était notre amour et nous l'avons
perdue a dit un proche de la famille au
début de la cérémonie
c'est normal tous les gens qui n'ont pas
de quel métier et se retrouve là et non
seulement et puis bon tous les amis pour
réconforter quand même la famille et
tout c'est un besoin
moi je dirais naturel pour être avec les
marins jour de deuil au village à 14
heures magasins et restaurants ont
baissé le rideau
un geste symbolique pour s'associer à la
cérémonie depuis hier des affiches
improvisées fleuriste ici et là une
quête est organisée pour les victimes du
naufrage
oléron se veut solidaire dans la
difficulté dans le métier on est assez
renfermé alors pas recevoir dès qu'il ya
un drame
en monde participe
on serre les coudes pour tous c'est 60
c'est le coeur qui parle
le travail passe après aujourd'hui aucun
bateau n'a quitté les quais de la
cotinière les chalutiers porte le deuil
des six morts et trois disparus dans le
naufrage de l' essor dans l' enquête sur
le hold up sur les reports de perpignan
les résultats de l enquête
administrative remise au préfet n'ont
pas encore été rendus publics mais ce
soir des policiers dénoncent les
carences du système de sécurité de
l'aéroport
des carences dont il avait informé
distille les autorités depuis déjà
quelques temps les eaux lamberton et
pascal pons au lendemain du hold up
le préfet des pyrénées-orientales a tenu
à informer la presse qu'il diligentait
une enquête administrative sur les
conditions d'alerté de sécurité à
l'aéroport
ce soir les conclusions de cette enquête
sont sur son bureau il ne les a pas
rendu public
or la plupart de ces conclusions il les
connaît déjà depuis longtemps
en effet en tant que plus haut
responsable de la sécurité sur
l'aéroport ils avaient été alertés
depuis des mois sur les problèmes qui
existaient ainsi pour surveiller en
aéroport international comme celui de
perpignan qui accueille jusqu'à 3000
passagers par jour et 18 rotations
d'avions il y a deux gendarmes de
permanence équipé de deux véhicules un
parent patrouille à chaque mouvement
d'avion c'était le cas mardi soir même
le commandant de l'aéroport reconnaît
que c'est peu c'est suffisant et pas
assez
c'est vrai que c'est suffisant pour
faire une surveillance pour déclencher
les alertes quand il y en a besoin
puisque ça a été fait dans ce cas là
c'est pas un moyen d'action contre
une intervention évident la police de
l'air et des frontières n'a pas de
véhicule pour intervenir en cas de
problème il y a un nom on lui a retiré
les armes de précision qu'elle possédait
quant aux caméras de surveillance elle
ne contrôle que les abords du parking de
l'aéroport
tout cela aurait été bien utile mardi
soir depuis des mois les policiers
réclament ses moyens en vain ce soir ils
s'interrogent sur le bien-fondé de l'
enquête diligentée par le préfet je ne
sais pas si c'est pour se dédouaner par
rapport à des choses que nous dénonçons
depuis très longtemps mais je pense que
encore une fois on a cherché à faire
payer le lampiste alors que les chaînes
je sais pas ce arnaud sens bien au delà
de chez nous en fait de l' enquête
administrative les policiers attendent
la réponse à une seule question pourquoi
mardi soir la tour de contrôle n'a
t'elle pas demandé à l'hélicoptère de la
sécurité civile basé à côté de prendre
les malfaiteurs en chasse un éleveur du
val d'oise a eu la surprise de trouver
48 de ses brebis égorgées ce matin elles
ont été victimes de deux molosses de
dogue allemand qui se sont échappés
d'une propriété voisine reportage
thibault de barbeyrac et michel
levasseur
les deux chiens se sont acharnés sur le
troupeau pendant plus de deux heures une
à une ses 47 brebis qui devait mettre
bas dans un mois ont été égorgés des
cadavres ont été retrouvés disséminées
sur plus de 5 hectares le reste du
troupeau n'est pas en très bon état
une vingtaine de bêtes blessées doivent
être achevés ces des chiens qui
apparemment ce sont
là pour tuer c'est pas le jeu c'est pas
le goût du sens c'est pas s'acharner sur
un animal c'est tuer tuer les uns après
les autres les chiens deux dogues
allemands ont été abattus par le
garde-chasse des dogues qui s'était
échappé le matin même de cette propriété
située à quelques kilomètres dans ce
château qui appartient à la comtesse
d'herbes et une élue front national du
conseil régional de picardie
les molosses dissuader les intrus ont
c'est un mal nécessaire parce que nous
sommes ici on ne propriété classée
monument historique
tous les châteaux des alentours ont déjà
été visités nous en vingt ans ça fait 20
ans qu'on a des chiens ce type de chien
notamment des dogues allemands et nous
n'avons jamais eu aucun problème
les chiens n'étaient donc apparemment
pas dresser pour attaquer mais il était
dangereux pour preuve le massacre d'hier
soir l'assurance du propriétaire devra
rembourser les 400 mille francs de
préjudice
la comtesse des rebelles risquent de
devoir payer en plus une amende de
plusieurs milliers de francs pour
divagation d'animaux en voile alain
gautier est attendue cette nuit à brest
il devrait retrouver sa famille et se
remettre de ses émotions après sa chute
dans la 2e étape de la solitaire du
figaro alain gautier a eu la chance
d'être repêché par un autre concurrent
nicolas bérenger après 30 minutes seul
dans l'eau céline géraud et yves jacques
alain gautier quatrième au classement
provisoire tombe à l'eau en voulant
dégager les algues de son safran il a
glissé sans pouvoir s'accrocher aux
buttes de sécurité prévus à cet effet et
au cours d'une manoeuvre pourtant
souvent répété j'étais pas louper et
donc c'est ici au large de l'angleterre
tout près des îles scilly que l'incident
s'est produit après 30 minutes dans une
mer à 15 degrés gauthier a été secouru
par l'un des poursuivants
coup de chance est question comment cet
incident peut-il arriver à un marin
expérimenté
vainqueur de la dernière transat lorient
saint barth et qui fêtait sa 13e
participation à la solitaire du figaro
qu'il a peut-être dépassé le seuil de
sécurité s'emparant de compte je crois
que son pouvoir était déjà mouillé parce
qu'ils avaient plusieurs fois déjà
mettre la tête sous l'eau pour regarder
justement s'il n'avait rien la pratique
doit être pour beaucoup mais il ya
forcément l'excitation de la course donc
on y perd du temps on a envie d'y
arriver on a envie de gagner et pillon
on dépasse un peu la limite et la limite
ça s'est résumé pour lui à tomber dans
l'eau gauthier a abandonné pour les
autres toujours un maire la moralité de
cette histoire c'est que dans le figaro
si l'on tombe à l'eau
mieux vaut être devant deux semaines
après les jeux olympiques atlanta
accueille les jeux paralympiques la
cérémonie d'ouverture s'est déroulée
dans le stade olympique devant 65 mille
personnes l'acteur est maigre et
américain christopher reeves paralysé
depuis une chute de cheval on a été le
maître de cérémonie jusqu'au 25 ou 3500
athlètes handicapés originaire de 127
pays vont devoir s'affronter le rang
frédéric bollée personne n'est à l'abri
d'un handicap
christopher rible c'est bien s'adressant
aux athlètes et leur dit vous
représentez le triomphe de l'esprit
humain dans le stade d'atlanta
70 spectateurs sont d'accord avec lui
les 10e jeux paralympiques peuvent
commencer à leur tour
évidemment ils sont moins médiatisés et
peut-être at-il fallu la course du 1500
m fauteuil pendant les jeux pour même
s'en souvenir
ce jour là le français claude y sera à
gagner il a aussi fait passer un message
le sport ne s'arrête pas quand les jeux
olympiques s'achève il continue après
alors pendant dix jours l'on va revoir
lombard vivre des instantanés de
douleurs de joie d'émotion quand la
souffrance physique permet de faire
oublier une autre troupe ans bien sûr
souvent les sportifs handicapés ont
besoin d' aide de repères et depuis peu
ou longtemps ils savent comme tout
sportif que leurs performances ne dépend
que 227 nation 3500 athlètes 19
disciplines les jeux paralympiques
accueille aussi cette année pour la
première fois des handicapés mentaux
la délégation française est forte de 145
sportif à barcelone elle avait récolté
106 médailles ce qui la plaçait au
quatrième rang mondial
est ce là le plus important sans doute
pas mais comme pour tout le monde
rien ne vaut le sentiment d'une victoire
c'est sans doute l'une des courses les
plus spectaculaires de l'année l'une des
plus anciennes aussi on l'appelle le
palio elle se court à sienne en italie
sur la fameuse place del campo la place
en éventail au centre de la ville mais
une course à cheval accrue chaque choqué
avec sa monture représente les couleurs
d'un quartier de la ville et vous allez
le voir tous les coups sont permis
bref que le palio de sienne
c'est une destination de vacances assez
peu connue mais elle a ses
inconditionnels les 136 camping ile de
france son treizième en plein en été et
vous allez le voir leurs habitués ne
viennent pas forcément de très loin le
baptisa et jacques gerra bienvenue à
paris
enfin presque ce petit coin de nature se
trouve en fait aux portes de la capitale
camping municipal s'est implantée là
depuis presque cinquante ans alors
forcément on y trouve des amitiés et
c'est bien le calme que la majorité des
campeurs viennent chercher ici en fait
plus de la moitié d'entre eux habitent à
peine à une dizaine de kilomètres de ce
camping la houle et le plaisir
y'a pas de la route rien à faire
encore plus étonnant on consomme un
petit peu trop on dort on dort le
dimanche soir ici dans la caravane raid
du matin sa voix tout frais tout beau
je travaillais pas loin les 20 minutes
et si certains viennent passer ici des
week-ends prolongés d'autres sont
vraiment en vacances et font tout pour
oublier la proximité de leur domicile
on évite d'y retourner le plus possible
on y est allé une fois en dix jours pour
des raisons badauds linge etc
monsieur tout ça fera presque 40 ans
genre les implantent leurs tentes
ici la moitié de l'année pour y trouver
la sensation d'une maison secondaire
les autres trouvent à bon marché une
échappatoire pour fuir leur cité quand
on est en hlm ont apprécié d'avoir un
coin de verdure pour faire un petit
barbecue prendre l'apéritif avec des
amis et puis se détend donc je crois
qu'on a à peu près résumé la philosophie
du camping le camping proche de paris et
surtout pas loin du domicile
une solution économique qui permet un
plus
de s'échapper
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi dans un instant la météo
de jean louis belleau qui nous annoncent
un temps estival pour tout le week-end
le dernier journal ce sera vers 23h55
christophe portera à 13 heures demain
vous retrouverez laurence piquet quant à
moi je vous retrouverai bien sûr demain
soir à 20h bonne soirée sur france 2